- [Mark] Did you always
tell stories with your eyes.
- [Johnny] Closed?
- [Mark] Do you always tell
stories with your eyes closed?
- Thinking, but I'm gonna switch that up.
(Mark laughs)
I was thinking about that right now
as you were talking.
- [Mark] I read the
comments on your videos.
(indistinct)
Say I'm, cause he's
high as fuck, tell 'em.
Tell 'em I'm not, that's no shame in mine.
I don't lie about me getting high.
That's normal.
All my family members,
everybody knows I get high.
I tell everybody.
- [Mark] I mean, Mexican
gang members and heroin,
they go together right?
- Oh yeah, hand in hand.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's the common thing.
- Yeah, like cookies and milk, you know,
cereal you know.
- [Mark] But the closed
eyes is about what?
It's just the way you concentrate?
- The closed yeah more or less.
See because when I'm speaking right here,
I wanna speak the actual truth
because I don't want no one
to get on that thing and say,
"Oh you're a lying motherfucker
because I was with you
that day and you know."
Or you you're lying you know,
that's why I told my
family they were like,
"Yeah, you know everything
you're talking about is true."
You know, with the, what they
got me about was the coconuts.
Cause I never told them
that we used to hide dope
in some of grandma's coconuts,
on top her TV I never told them.
So my aunts were like,
"That's where that shit was
we used to smell it and you know,
we couldn't find out where was it."
That's where it was at at all times.
But whenever you're ready, Mark,
are you ready?
- [Mark] I'm ready.
I'm ready for it.
- Oh, it's about the middle of March.
Huh Mark, it's pretty hot.
You know, but today I was
gonna talk a little bit about
growing up in the hood
and having family members
that are from my hood
and that are family
members from another hood
that were actually enemies.
And how we go about, how I
go about it and work it out.
You know, I got, I got like
four cousins throughout Norwalk.
They're out of one side of Norwalk.
Cause I got cousins from Varrio Norwalk
and then I got cousins from
Peaceful Varrio Norwalk,
and it's two different neighborhoods
but I got cousins from there you know.
And I grew up with them, you know.
It's my mom's sister's sons, you know,
there's like four of them,
you know, and two of them,
they're kinda the main guys
from that hood but you know,
as growing up through the years,
you know I remember when I was younger
and I used to go visit my grandma's house,
you know, my mom's mother.
And I used to go over there
and there were my cousins
with their homeboys, you know what I mean?
And we were already enemies.
Our hoods didn't get along.
We had been already at
it for years and years
but I used to go to my grandma's house
and you know, if you step
into your grandma's house,
you know these dudes
used to try to tell me
that that was their hood.
And I used to tell 'em look,
"Beyond his front yard,
beyond this backyard,
or beyond this front door
of my grandmother's house,
yeah that's your hood."
But when you step in
my grandmother's house
and you go to the backyard
that no longer is your hood,
it may be in your hood,
but yet that's my grandmother's house.
So really that's my hood, you know?
So, you know one time we're
down there, we were visiting.
And one of my cousins' homeboys came,
he's an older dude you
know, he's been around.
I heard about him through
the years you know,
he was from that hood and he was one
of the main characters out of there.
But this dude he just kept
talking and talking and talking
and he was a lot older, you know?
And I was always taught by my older homeys
and my family members to
always respect your elders
you know, always, excuse
me, you know what I mean?
Pardon me?
You know what I mean?
Always, you know, help a
lady across the street,
you know all the good things.
Things that make you up, make
you you know, a gentleman.
So I'm always, you know, calm
and collected most of the time
and this dude is going at
it and he's going at it,
and he's disrespecting my homeys.
He's talking bad about my uncles.
You know what I mean?
And this dude just going on and on and on.
So I tell him, "Well, you know what?"
I tell him, "Look, you're
a little bit older."
I said and, "You know why don't
you bring your little homeys
that are my age, you know?
And you go ahead and line them up."
So me thinking that I told dude this,
that he wasn't gonna do it.
But there he goes, he
left, you know what I mean?
And we're kicking back in
my grandmother's backyard.
We're getting drunk and shit.
You know, we're partying with
my cousins from that hood.
And here comes two carloads.
They get off the car
and there must be about
Oh man, there must be about
eight or nine youngsters that are my size.
I mean, I'm there, my
little brother's there.
It's just me and my
little brother, you know,
the rest of these dudes are from Norwalk.
And so me and my little
brother are there so,
he brings the guys up and
they're all standing right there
and I tell him, "Well, you
know I told you to line 'em up,
you know so, who's first?"
well, I guess when he had
went to go get these guys
they had picked this dude
because he was supposed to be
going for his golden gloves and
you know, he had been boxing
for like four or five years, you know
and at first, when he, when I seen him,
and I heard his name,
I already had did my homework on this dude
because I had tried to
get at his sister previous
and she didn't want nothing to do with me
cause her brother was my enemy.
So, she didn't wanna get caught up.
So I kinda knew who this guy was.
Well, they brought him to,
you know the middle of the
yard, you know what I mean
and those little dudes,
the older homeys watching
he got all his little homeys right there.
You know, it's me and my little brother.
But like I said, that's
my grandmother's house.
So my cousins that are
there, they're my cousins.
They ain't gonna let their homeys jump me
but they were gonna let us go head up.
So, I end up going head up with this dude
and Imma be honest, I
handled whooping his ass.
You know, he might be
hearing this story right now
and he knows exactly who it is.
So, you know, I'm not running no bullshit.
But I ended up whooping his ass you know
and I remember whooping his
ass and I'm on top of him
that older dude comes and he
fucking snatches me off of him.
And he throws me to the
side and I tell him,
"I told you, man, bring your
homeys and line 'em up."
Well what happened was since
I beat up this first guy,
I didn't know that this first guy was
had more balls or had
more courage or whatever
or was a badder motherfucker
than the rest of his homeys.
This was like the main dude.
I guess they expected him to whoop my ass
and just get it over with.
But when the tables turned,
The older dude started
telling his little homeys,
"Hey man, get in there."
None of them wanted to step in.
You know, I'm talking about, stepping
the little circle we made
with the benches and shit
in my grandma's backyard.
None of them wanted to step in.
So now, this older dude's getting mad,
and he starts fucking
slapping his little homeys
you know, he's slapping his little homeys
and I'm like, "What the fuck man?"
You know what I mean?
"Why are you slapping these fools?"
You know, I go just because
a dude don't wanna fight, man
you know you ain't in here fighting.
I mean, you walk with a limp,
you're an older homey,
we're not disrespecting you.
I say but, "If you want
I'll go get my older homeys
and bring them down here
and you can fucking fight with them."
You know what I mean?
I said, "I sure the
fuck ain't gonna try to
slap my homeys around
just because they don't
wanna get in and fight with
an individual they
don't wanna fight with."
I said, "I'm not saying they're scared,
or you know, they don't got the balls,
I'm just saying bottom line they seen
their homeys ass get whooped,
maybe he whooped all their asses
and they just don't want
the same ass whooping I gave him."
Well, this dude gets hot and he gets mad
and he starts talking about,
he's gonna go get this,
and he's gonna get this out of his trunk
and this out of his trunk.
So now inside my head,
I'm saying, you know what?
This dude went too far now,
you know, he went too far.
Cause now he's talking
about hurting people
about coming back and
lighting up the whole house.
And I'm like, I'm looking at my cousin.
That's from that hood,
and I'm like, "Look, you hear your homey
what he's saying right?"
Saying he's gonna come
back and like the house up.
You know, this is our grandmother's house.
You know, are you gonna check your homey
or am I gonna have to call my homeys?
Well, my cousin let it go too long.
So I ended up getting on the
phone and calling my homeys.
It was a trip cause my homeys
got there within 10 minutes
two carloads they got there.
I remember my homey gets off the car
he gets off the car with a 22 rifle.
And he gots like 38
rounds in it or something.
He got the banana clip.
And I remember we get on the back fence
and my homeys went to
go look for these dudes.
So my homeys cruised around,
here comes my homey in his car,
he parks it, he gets
off, he runs in the yard,
here, comes the two carloads.
And I remember them coming
by and they were gonna stop.
But what happened was my homey
just started lighting off on 'em.
And I remember when he
was lighting off on 'em.
I could see sparks
hitting the top of the car
and the side of the car, you know
sparks flying off the
cars everywhere, you know
and they were hitting him, you know
sparking off the car,
sparking off the car.
And you know, I remember I was laughing
because my homey just
stayed, letting them have it.
And I could hear the girls screaming
and the fools yelling inside the cars
and I could see the bullets
ricocheting off and shit.
And it was real late at night
it might've been about
three in the morning.
You know what I mean?
And you know, I tell that
story because of the fact that,
you know, I was about 13 years old,
that older dude was
about 28, 29, you know?
And you know, I told
him to go get his homeys
he went and got them, you know,
I beat the first one up.
So the next row of them
didn't wanna fight.
You know what I mean?
But it's peculiar because
after that happened, you know
I kinda started talking to a
few of the guys from that hood
because like I said my
cousins were from that hood
and you know I used to go in there,
but I used to use a different name.
You know, when I went in Norwalk
I used a different name, you know.
In different cities I used
to do use different names
because certain fools
knew me by a certain name.
And if I was stuck in this hood
and they knew exactly who I was,
I don't think I would
make it out of there.
You know, I used to go
in, in Norwalk, you know
and I got like, man, like
15 cousins from Norwalk
all older dudes, you know,
been around, you know
the main cats there and stuff.
And I used to go in there
and I used to go in there under
a different name, you know?
And I remember there was a couple of times
a couple of fools seen me that
I was in juvenile hall with,
I was in juvenile camp with
and I thought they were
gonna pull my covers.
You know, I thought they
were gonna tell these dudes
"Nah man, this ain't so-and-so."
And give them my real name.
If he would've gave them my real name
I think they would have did me dirty.
I think they would've really,
they would have got rid of me
because of the fact that, you know
we were going at it with them as well.
But now I was going to my aunt's house
and I feel when you stay up
in somebody's house, you know
and whether it's your in-laws
or whether it's your
instant family, you know
all the gang banging stops.
But there's a lotta dudes that
they don't take that and use that.
They more or less take advantage of that.
You know what I mean?
I mean, I went to my grandmother's house
where my cousin had like
10 of his homeys there
and they're just like looking at us
like they wanna just tear us apart
But being that, these are my cousins
that's my grandma's house,
you know, there was no way that
I was gonna let these fools
make me leave or tell me
that I couldn't be there
or anything like that because I told them
time and time again, beyond this doorstep,
that's your hood
but in here, nah, this is my hood.
This is my grandmother's house.
You know what I mean?
(indistinct)
Easy as that, you know what I mean?
Well, that was that, you know what I mean?
That was that with them, you
know, they're from one gang.
So then I go to another gang,
go to the bigger Norwalk
and these dudes, man, my cousins,
like I said they're like 15 of them,
they were young, older
you know what I mean?
And I used to go in there and
I remember I used to sit down
and there must've been 30, 40 dudes
from that hood right there, you know?
And they're all looking at
me, you know what I mean?
And I introduce myself as someone else
cause I told my cousins
if they hear my name man,
my ass is grass you know?
So, cause I was messing
with some other homegirls
and I was coming in their hood
kicking it with their homeys.
But I used to go in there, you know,
and I used to go to my aunt all the time
and I remember used to sit with my aunt
and I would see these fucking
dudes crossing the window
and they'd be looking at me like, you know
like they wanted to get me, you know
and my aunt would be telling them
get the fuck away from
the window, you know?
And I'd be laughing because you know
I knew they weren't gonna do anything.
They were gonna huff and puff out there
and they were gonna talk their shit,
but when it came down to it,
I knew that my cousins weren't gonna allow
their homeys to do anything
to me and my little brother
except maybe go one-on-one
and fight with them.
And I used to love to fight.
You know, that was my thing.
I was taught you know, when
I was a youngster that,
you know the way my father used to tell me
that they used to do it.
And since he was an older guy
he was from my hood,
he was my older homey.
He said that they used to get in, you know
one group right here and
one group right here,
and they used to get the
toughest fool out of each group
and let them go head up.
And that would decide everything.
You know, there wasn't no rumble,
there wasn't no jumping this
fool or jumping that fool.
So, as I grew up, you know
I could actually sit here and tell you,
I've never jump anybody.
I've never jumped
anybody with someone else
or I've never been jumped myself.
And a lotta people say,
"Oh, come on you've been jumped."
No I have never been jumped.
All the years that I was low riding,
being a cholo, gang banging.
All the years that I was doing that,
I never ever got jumped.
I got close to getting jumped,
but I guess because I gave
so dudes the opportunity
and these fools that are
watching this, know that
if you know me personally
and you were my enemy
I always give you the opportunity
to come from the shoulders.
Always, you know, always.
And if you didn't want it like that
well then we could get back to back,
take 10 paces and turn
around and shoot each other.
It didn't matter to me.
The thing about it was is that
it was pushed in me so much
by my father and my uncles
that they wanted us to earn our name
with these, not with this, you know?
And when I was younger growing up
it wasn't about a drive by.
It wasn't nothing like that.
It was all about,
you know,
just mainly fights
mainly fights after school.
You know what I mean?
Or you know, at lunchtime,
you know what I mean?
And I remember this one time
we go to this arcade they had,
and you know we used
to go deep over there,
maybe like 30, 40 of us.
And I went to watch a fight.
You know, I watched these, I watched one
of my partners get down
with some other guy.
And I remember as they're fighting,
I'm rooting for my homey
and this dude next to me
is rooting for the other dude.
And this guy next to me ends
up elbowing me you know.
Because you know we're trying to
make room for them to fight.
And he ends up elbowing me.
So, I turn around and
as soon as I tell him,
"what's up motherfucker?"
The whole crowd, just,
(Johnny makes a whooshing sound)
you know what I mean?
We're stuck in the middle, you know
and this dude's kinda big,
you know, he's kinda big
but I know I'm gonna hurt him.
So, one thing leads to another.
I end up busting his whole snot box.
He's bleeding everywhere.
You know what I mean?
They're talking about
calling the ambulance
now this dude like, I
didn't even break his nose.
He just busted his snot box.
You know what I mean?
I went into the arcade after, you know.
Yeah, I felt like I was on
top of the world you know.
But, I remember that
once I beat this dude up
I went to my grandmother's
house, the following week
and who's sitting at my cousin's,
in my cousin's room?
The same dude that beat up now
he's from my cousin's hood.
And I got at him, I asked him, I said,
"You know what why are
you from this hood now?"
You know, is it because
we got down last week
and I beat you up?
You know, why do you
gotta be from their hood?
You know what I mean?
This dude was from running around with us,
but then a lotta the guys did that
they ran around with us
and then they got into different hoods.
And the reason I bring it
up is because, you know
on my father's side, it's like everybody's
from my neighborhood.
All my cousins, my brothers,
my sisters, everybody.
I mean, I wish you would see a photo.
You know, I might just have
to bring one the next time
and show you a photo of how deep
my family members are and how many of them
are from my neighborhood.
You know, there's at
least I can say 25 of us.
I'm talking about women, men of all ages.
There's like three or four generations.
You know?
So, most of the stuff I talk about
I talk about me and my family members,
the shit we do because we did so much shit
and there's so many of us that,
you know someone's gonna go to
come along and call my bluff.
If I'm up here bullshitting
about anything in general.
You know, but I just like to talk about,
you know me myself and things
I've experienced, you know.
When I was younger, you know.
I've been in so many situations where,
you know, a couple of times
I've been in a hood where
I'm doing business you
know, and I get caught.
I get caught.
They catch me.
You know what I mean?
They got guns and everything
and they wanna fucking get at my ass.
And all I do is tell them,
"Hey man, go to the third
number on my phone and dial."
You know what I mean?
That's all I'm gonna say,
you know what I mean?
Cause they're there and they're
there to take all my shit.
And I tell 'em, go ahead, take it.
Take it, it ain't mine so fuck it.
Take it.
You know what I mean?
Once you tell them that,
then they start asking themselves
you know, what's going on?
I can't give too much
information and I never do,
but I just let them know if you
want call that third number,
you know what I mean?
Then you guys will know what time it is
because time and time again, I've heard,
you know I'm over here doing shit.
You know what I mean.
I'm doing shit in the right
way, in the right fashion.
But you always have that
hater in the background.
That wants to say you're making more
than you're actually making.
Like they wanna get you
living amongst your means.
That's the wording they
use, the terminology.
Living beyond your
means that's what it is.
It's called living beyond your means.
It's like a motherfucker's gots a BMW 2020
parked at a fucking shack
right there in Compton
in the fucking hood,
have a fucking $107,000
car he got it parked
in front of a fucking little ass shack.
You know what I mean?
That his mom lives in.
You know, that's the type
of motherfucker that's
living beyond his means.
You know me, I was always one
that I just wanted to live comfortable.
I just wanted to stay high,
have enough to share,
have enough to make money
and also have enough
to touch the ones that
really don't have anything.
Maybe the winos over
there, the bums, you know.
I'm always giving dollars up.
I'm always giving dope up.
You know, that's just me, you know.
But a lotta times you'd
have those people that
that wanna go around and
talk about your business.
You know what I mean?
And when I used to go to different cities,
and my cousins lived out there,
I used to go to my family's house
and do my, all my business there.
But you would always have these guys man
that would be talking about
your business left and right.
Telling women, you know what I mean
telling their older homeys
and they'd make it bigger
than it would actually was.
You know, I'd be selling maybe dimes
and these fools would swear,
that I'm moving pounds
in their hood, you know?
And it's like, you know,
it's so fucked up because you know,
half these dudes that
were talking about me
I'm taking care of them you know?
And if I'm not taking care of them direct
I'm taking care of them
through their homegirl.
You know, because mainly
I was dealing with women
because women they deal
dope a little bit different than men do.
You know what I mean?
We're on it and we want it now,
We ain't hearing shit,
but now women are more finessing.
You know, they're more
we'll wait for the money
a little bit longer you know,
they got patience you know.
and I mean I've dealt
with my homegirls where,
I mean they made so much money
that I couldn't believe how
fast they would move the shit.
You know what I mean?
And, the reason they were moving it,
number one cause it was good.
Number two, cause they weren't
gonna get told anything.
But then again, you always
got that same motherfucker
that wants to come around,
try to mix my homegirl up,
You know what I mean?
Put shit in her head,
you know what I mean?
And then my homegirl
go do something stupid,
and then I gotta exile her ass.
And you know I've exiled
a lotta my homegirls.
And what I mean by exile is exile.
You no longer come around.
You don't come to the hood,
you don't call the hood,
you don't cruise through the hood,
you don't walk through the hood.
This is no longer your hood, you know.
And that has to be something
very, very critical.
Like for instance,
I acquire something,
and I wrap it up and put
it away and never touch it.
But yet she comes and grabs it
and puts it somewhere else
thinking she's doing me a favor
but the bitch actually fucked up
three months of me setting something up,
it took her three minutes
to just fuck that all off.
Why?
Because she put her hand on it.
Because nobody's hands
were supposed to be on it.
And you the ones that
know what time it is.
You know what I'm talking about.
You know?
And that's the type of individual I was
when I set something up, I would set it up
like a two week advance,
you know and I would make sure everything,
all my ducks were in a row, you know.
Nobody was touching anything,
nobody was knowing anything.
They would talk about it when it was done.
You know what I mean?
And I also used to have to be careful
because I used to go through some hoods
and like I said, I got a lotta
family members from there.
I didn't wanna hurt the wrong individual.
So, sometimes I would call
and kinda, you know ask
around who's around there.
You know what I mean?
And a lotta times it'd be my cousins.
You know, I'm not gonna
sit here and tell you
that I haven't shot at my cousins.
Yeah I shot at my cousins several times.
Where I shot at my cousins one time
was inside my own home in
front of my grandmother,
you know, I shot at this,
I shot at my cousin because you know
he was totally disrespecting
inside our home.
Yeah we may be enemies on the streets
but now you're inside our home,
you're a family member,
so you need to act like one.
Well he wasn't acting like that.
He was disrespecting me,
he's disrespecting my little brother.
My grandmother told him to be quiet,
he got loud with her,
his mom, my aunt told him to
be quiet he got loud with her.
Once he got loud with her, he
got loud with my grandmother
I told my grandma, "Boom, I'll be back."
As soon as I stepped out
my grandmother told him
she better leave cause she
knew where I was going.
I was going to my spot.
I was gonna get my weapon
and I was gonna put a hole
in this little fucker,
for disrespecting my
grandmother's house, you know?
And no one does that, no one's allowed
to disrespect that house.
You couldn't shoot at that house,
you couldn't gang bang on that house.
You were allowed to do
nothing with that house.
But because he's my cousin
and he feels he gots to like that.
He wants to disrespect,
You know what I mean?
Call a motherfucker punk,
you know what I mean?
Tell me I ain't shit,
And why?
Cause his homegirl I'm being with her
and he's jealous because
he wants to be with her.
You know, a lotta times that happened.
You know, I ended up going to a hood
and meet this fine ass broad.
And I'm not knowing that
this is their main homegirl.
Like this is their pride and joy.
You know, all their homeboys
look up to this bitch.
Like, cause she's so fine.
You know, they, they
put her on a pedestal.
I end up being with her and
then now the is like nothing.
You know what I mean?
And a lotta times I would tell them,
"I'm sorry, you know I didn't know
that this was gonna take place?"
But that's the way your homeboys are.
You know what I mean?
They, they wanna act like they love you
and they cherish you.
But now you're tainted,
Why?
Because you're with me?
What the fuck are they
doing in their spare time?
You know what I mean?
And I used to catch a lotta
fools from different hoods
in my neighborhood
being with my homegirls.
If they were being with my homegirls,
I wouldn't put them out there.
I wouldn't go get my homeys
and come and fuck them up.
Nah, because then I'm
disrespecting my homegirl.
Maybe she likes this guy.
You know what I mean?
And yeah, he's my enemy.
But that's on her
When it comes down to it
and they pull her fucking card,
she's gonna have to answer
for her fucking with this dude.
So really, I used to let that go.
You know, a lotta in my hood I let go.
I used to catch fools in
there from different hoods
and I just let them go.
And I used to tell them,
go ahead, man, walk through.
I can't speak for the
dudes on the next block
that they're not gonna fuck you up,
but me, I'm not gonna go out of my way
and fuck you up because first of all,
you're just walking through here.
I know you wanna go all the way around.
I said, but there's some
of your homeys that,
nah I ain't gonna let
them walk through here.
They have no business walking through here
because there's a main
street on that side,
and there's a main street on that side.
Your old lady might live down this way
but you can go fucking around.
Cause if you go, if you go by my house
and you cruise by and you're looking,
Imma look at you.
If you bust a U-turn,
Imma send my kids in, send the dog in,
Imma go get my shit, come out,
you go by again Imma
give you one more look.
If you fucking make another U-turn,
Imma fucking light you up
when you come by the third time.
Because the first time you came by,
I'm figuring, you're just
checking out who's around.
You know what I mean?
To see who you can get with,
maybe you got personal
shit one of my homeys,
but then when you bust a U-turn,
Oh man, now you're looking for trouble.
You're looking for trouble.
But now if you turn back the third time,
you're looking to hurt somebody
so Imma hurt you first.
And many at times that has happened.
You know, when I shot at my cousin,
I shot at him out my bedroom window.
I shot at him in his mom's car.
I hit his mom's car like two times,
my aunt got upset, you know
and she yelled and everything
she wanted my grandmother to fucking
whoop my ass and everything.
But my grandmother seen where
I was coming from, you know
and I was her favorite,
but at the same time
he just didn't disrespect me,
he disrespected his mother,
my grandmother, his aunt.
He disrespected the whole family.
You know, he disrespected my home.
And at that time, you know,
I might've been 16 years old
but I was the one taking care
of business for my family.
You know what I mean?
I was the one that came to
when there was a problem.
I was the one to go deal with it.
I was the one to go take care of it.
You know what I mean?
And to be honest with you,
the shit got old.
You know what I mean?
It got old, after a while,
I was asking myself, you know,
why are they laying all
the problems on my hands?
You know, I got seven
cousins, seven uncles
and they're just as fucking tough, man.
They're just as fucking bad, man.
They'd been to prison more times than me
but yet when someone wants
to come talk to somebody
they wanna call me, bring me from my home,
bring me out of what I'm doing,
so I could go talk, come
and talk to somebody.
When, in all reality they can
talk to them just as well.
You know what I mean?
But they always wanna put me there.
So I do the talking, then that ties me in,
the next thing I know,
I'm in my hood again,
I got the fucking keys and
I'm fucking hating life.
I'm hating life because I cannot move.
I'm obligated by something to stay there
and make sure everything goes good.
And, because of the obligation,
I'm fucked.
You know what I mean?
I can't even go spend
time with my little girl,
I can't go spend time with my wife.
You know what I mean?
I'm right here posted up 24 hours a day.
Making sure everything's going
according to plan, you know
and I used to trip because I get my homeys
and we'll have our
little meetings and shit.
And I remember when I used to say,
"Okay, well here, this is
your street and your spot."
And then my homey over
here would get upset.
"Why are you giving it to him?"
You know?
And I used to get that all the time
and I used him look,
"The way it looks right now is
everybody's smoking dope."
Motherfuckers are coming through
they're writing on the walls,
you know, up in the pad.
I mean, when I was busted, there was fools
my enemies up in my house
being with my cousins.
And they were in my
house where I grew up at.
And I was really upset about that.
You know what I mean?
And when I got out, I told my homeys
I can't believe that these
fools were up in this house.
It's like the main house in the hood.
And we got our enemies
laying up in here all night.
Even if I was in prison,
you motherfuckers shoulda came
and removed these fools out of here.
You know what I mean?
They were actually in here,
I felt kinda sick from my stomach.
When I walked in my house,
when I got out of prison
I walked in my house.
I felt kinda sick from my
stomach because I was imagining
that these motherfuckers were up in here,
just kicking it, eating
out the refrigerator,
laying on the sofa,
like it was their spot.
I could just imagine what they were saying
to their homeys when they went back.
Oh yeah, we're in this house,
last name and all that shit.
And it used making me real upset.
Matter of fact, even one of my cousins
had a baby from one of the fools
that used to go to my house, you know?
And I seen him after
I got with his program
I hurt him pretty bad, but you know,
the reason I hurt him so bad was
because he was the one that
used to go to the house
and just disrespect, you know?
Cause we were all busted.
All the younger boys from
my family, we're all busted.
We're all in prison.
You know, one was in
(indistinct)
but the rest were in prison.
All my uncles were older.
They were living their lives.
So really no one was out there.
It was just a lot of the
cousins that were girls.
And you know, they had
all fucking kinds of fools
from everywhere coming and visiting.
You know, I'd be in
prison, and a fool be like,
"Hey I've been to this house
right here in this spot."
And I'd be like, "Okay, you've been there,
tell me what's on the
walls in the living room."
And they gotta tell me
exactly what's there
cause if they don't tell me
what's in the living room
they've never been to my house.
I've caught many motherfuckers and liars
and I asked them, "What's
in the living room?"
There was only three things
in the living room walls.
On one of the walls, it
was an Aztec calendar,
on the other side of the wall
there was a clock, an old clock.
And in the middle side of the wall
it was a portrait of my uncle, Black Bob.
He was a portrait of him
and the Pancho Villa days,
the civil war days, you
know, with the big white
pearl-handled gun, with
the cross top bullets
with the sombrero hat back,
you know, big old mustache,
long ass hair.
You know it was a portrait of him
and I used to ask dudes, you know,
"Well, what's on the walls in there?"
You know, and like I said
the walls are just blank.
It's just the picture of him,
the Aztec calendar, and a clock, you know?
And when fools would tell me, "
Oh, there's some pictures up."
You're fucking lying, bro.
You're lying.
But now if a dude told me,
"Oh, well there's a picture
of your uncle on the wall."
Okay, boom you've been there.
You know what I mean?
And a lotta fools used to try to like
you know, take the credit
that they used to go
to my house because they
were related to the family.
But, I tricked out
because I even had cousins
that wouldn't come over.
You know, and I would
call 'em and tell 'em,
"Hey man you know, when you come over
my homeys ain't gonna trip, you know,
you're my cousin, fuck
what they're thinking."
"Nah I ain't gonna go over there
I already know how you guys are."
Wasn't even like that, but
a lotta times, you know,
I would go over there to their house
and I knew exactly what they would feel
because you know, maybe their
homeys weren't saying shit,
but in the back, they're staring at me.
You know what I mean?
Fuck you, you know me shit like that.
And I'm like, "Yeah, you
ain't gonna do shit."
But it was just you
know, being from my hood
having so many family
members from the hood,
and then having a lotta family
members from other hoods,
made it real difficult
as I was growing up.
You know what I mean?
Because, this is my family,
you know what I mean?
And a lotta times there'll
be with their homeys.
And like, if I show up
at my grandma's house
and there's like 10 of them there,
you know they want my
ass, you know what I mean?
Even though my cousins
would step up and be like,
"Hey man, fuck that,
you ain't gonna do nothing to my cousins."
They want my ass for other reasons.
They don't want my ass just
because they want my ass.
They want my ass because the
last weekend, when I came
to their hood and lit their ass up
or I stabbed their homeboy,
or I beat their homey up,
they want my ass behind that.
A lotta times they wanted
my ass because like I said,
I was messing with their main homegirl.
And I didn't know that she was like
a prized possession of them.
She was like, top-notch bitch.
I didn't know that, you know what I mean.
I mean, one time I even
got caught on a swing
with one of their main
homegirls from East LA somewhere
and all her homeys caught us.
All I had was a blanket around me
butt naked, with her butt naked,
we're on a swing inside the
little fucking like playground.
And these fuckers surround me.
I had a 357 right tucked
away but they caught me
and the way they were
looking at me was like,
I don't they expected me
to take the blanket off
and let them see their
homegirl naked or what
but I'm telling her like,
fuck, what do we do?
Who do we do?
You know, because she's
telling me don't worry.
And she's telling her
homeboy leave man, leave.
He's upset because he's
all in love with her.
I didn't know this.
If I woulda known this from jump,
I woulda never touched abroad.
Because motherfuckers are
serious about their homegirls.
Serious about the girls.
You know what I mean?
Motherfucker will kill you over a bitch.
And that's one thing I never wanted.
You know what I mean?
But I always to put it back
on their homegirl, you know.
I said, "You told me that your homey liked
you but you didn't tell me
that you were with them before,
and that you're still leading them on."
Cause a lotta times women would do that.
You know, women would lead
their fucking homeboy on
and then go be with another
fool from another hood.
They would end up getting into it,
kill one another behind her.
So, I didn't wanna be a statistic.
You know what I'm saying?
Most of all, I didn't wanna
hurt one of my cousins.
You know, cause I also had girl cousins
that were older, had
them that were younger.
Had girl cousins that's sold dope.
You know, I remember I
went to this house one time
and I knocked on the
door to buy some drugs.
And when the door opened,
the lady looked at me
and she's like, "You look
real familiar you know,
what's your name?"
I told her my name lo and behold.
I didn't know that this was my cousin.
You know what I mean?
I was going in her house.
And then I'm over buying some drugs that
she knows I ain't using.
So she's like, " Who
you we these drugs for?"
And I'm like, "Well they're
for the older homey, you know?"
And she's like, "Well I don't even wanna
put it in your hand."
I'm like, "It's not for me."
You know, "It's for them."
You know, "I don't use that shit."
And at that time it was heroin.
I was like, maybe like 16.
And she and I was going
to pick up a whole piece
and she didn't wanna put it in my hand.
And I was telling her, "Look,
I gave you the money already,
I need to take this back cause
if I don't take this back,
it's my ass you know?"
And she didn't want
to, she didn't want to.
So finally I called my homey,
I told him, "Hey man, she
don't wanna give it to me."
And then she broke it down
and she gave it to me.
But being that she was my cousin, you know
and she didn't wanna get
caught up with my grandmother.
And have to tell her, Oh yeah
well I gave him a whole piece
of heroin, you know?"
And I don't even use the shit.
You know what I'm saying?
I remember, you know, they
used to bring so much dope
to the house or when they
used to come knock on the door
like three in the morning.
Oh my God.
They used to come knock on the door.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
We'll go to the door, I'll
go to the door I'll listen,
boom, boom, boom.
Here comes my grandmother.
She'll get up, "What the hell?"
Turn the light on.
She'll go to the door
and she'll open the door.
And the person on the other side
of the door would be all
fucked up talking about.
"Could I buy a 20."
They're asking my grandmother,
if they can buy at 20 of dope,
when they should be asking me or my cousin
or they're asking my grandmother
because they're so high.
So now my grandmother knows,
one of you fuckers is selling drugs.
She knew that, she
couldn't pinpoint who is
but she's telling me, I know
one of you motherfuckers
are selling drugs because last night
at three in the morning,
well she wasn't lying cause I heard,
homegirl came to the door
banging on the door for a fucking 20 dip.
You know what I mean?
My grandmother was like, "What the fuck,
get the fucking hell out of my house."
You know what I mean?
And I'd be just laying still like,
Oh shit, you know what I mean?
And in the morning I
tell my little brother,
"Why do you have these smoker ass bitches
coming to the door two,
three in the morning
asking grandma, to sell
her some fucking dope?
Because you know, homegirls
and homeboys out there.
They're always gonna be there,
I learned that they're
always gonna be there.
And I also learned that they
do some stupid ass shit.
You know, you can just imagine,
them going to your house
and asking your grandmother
to sell them some dope.
You know?
I said, tell my homegirls,
how old are you?
You know you're not a little kid.
Why would you go to my grandma's house
and knock on the door
and ask her to buy dope?
I didn't know it was your grandmother?
You didn't know what was my grandmother?
How in the fuck?
You've known my grandmother for 30 years.
How in the fuck you're
gonna sit here and lie now?
Now you're gonna lie now
you ain't getting shit.
So I end up putting my
homegirls on restriction.
They can't buy no dope.
They'd be mad for a little bit,
but yet they fuck mines off
because now when I wake up in the morning,
that's the first thing I'm gonna hear
from my grandmother is,
who in the fuck is selling
drugs out of my house?
You know, I ain't telling on myself,
I sure ain't gonna tell
on my little brother
or my cousins they ain't gonna tell on me.
But now we're all gonna get lined up,
and grandmother is
getting, my grandfather is
gonna get his favorite
fucking bigg ass stick
and whip it across our back
because a fucking homegirl
came to the house last
night, asking for drugs.
So we'd all get whipped in
the back with a big ass stick.
And it was like nine of us.
Sometimes he'd break
the stick on one of us
and he'll fucking don't move,
and he'll fucking throw
the little piece down
and go get the other piece
and just go to town with that.
You know, so many times he's
broke it over one of our backs.
He used to hit us with a stick.
He used to hit us with the
fucking back of a ax handle.
He used to fucking put
his belt around his hand
and sock us dead in the jaw.
I remember he socked me in front
of my girlfriend, right in my jaw.
He socked me so hard, I seen those little
lights fly around and shit.
You know what?
I never got hit by my grandfather.
It was just that I think
I was going to school,
and he was gonna take me
but my girlfriend was there
and she was complaining
and I was arguing with her.
And then he said something
and I said something wrong to him.
He ended up putting on a glove
and sock me dead in the
jaw, right in front of her.
You know what I mean?
And I felt embarrassed.
My grandfather socked me in my mouth
in front of my girlfriend.
You know, now Imma fuck my
girlfriend up, you know?
And Imma tell her, I'm
gonna fuck you up you know
cause she's the one talking shit
and I'm trying to go to school, you know?
And you know, I was getting
an education at the same time
being a gang member,
but I had my grandfather taking me
to school and picking me up.
You know what I mean?
And this was now I was young 15, 16.
I was in some fucking school
that no one else went to.
You know?
And you know, I remember my grandfather,
I wasn't the only one he beat up.
He beat up all my cousins, all my uncles.
And I seen him beat up everybody.
For some reason, I was always there.
And he was the type of motherfucker where
he'd catch you by yourself
and he'd tell you,
don't move, don't move.
And he'll look around, no one's there,
and he'll just fucking cock back and
crack!
Right in the fucking jaw.
Hard too, I've seen him
fucking put my uncles to sleep.
He wouldn't hit us as hard,
but he'd sock everybody in the jaw.
And I've seen him sock all my uncles
and all my cousins in
the jaw, all of them.
Then he socked me in the jaw
and I used to laugh at them and tell them.
But once I got socked in the jaw,
I was like, Oh shit my
grandfather didn't play.
You know what I mean?
He was a real honest, you know
what I mean, hardworking man.
You know what I mean?
And I remember he used to
say, I was in the army.
I was an army, you know?
And he was in World War II, you know?
And he used to tell us, you
know, I kill for a reason
you guys are out here
killing for no reason.
You guys are just out there killing.
Why don't you go to the service
and go kill for a reason you know?
And I used to tell him,
it's just like the service.
I said, we got guns, we
got army, they got an army.
And we just go at it
and he used to tell me,
yeah but you do it for a reason.
He said, I killed for a reason.
You know?
And, he had a lotta
confirmed kills, you know
through his shit you know.
He boxed in the service and all that.
He was a truck driver, retired.
So anything he put forward, he had backup.
You know what I'm saying?
So he used to tell us to
get a job, go to work.
But on the other side,
flip side of the coin
my grandmother, would let us
buy the big baggy clothes,
the pendletons, the fucking hairnets.
You know, she would let
us dress like a gangster,
but my grandfather totally opposite.
He wanted us all to be workers.
And we were caught up, man, you know.
From generation to generation,
you know, we didn't have to get jumped in.
We walked dead in, as soon
as we turned 13 years old,
we're in the hood.
You know, I think my
little brother was like 11.
And my youngest cousin was like 10
but he was like off the hook.
You know, he was young, but
they had the brain capability
of thinking like an adult.
You know, these fools were
young, but they thought
at a different level, you know.
They carried themselves,
when I seen 'em running
with the certain guys
they were running with.
I couldn't believe my eyes.
Cause I wouldn't even run
with these motherfuckers.
The fools they were running with
I wouldn't even run with them.
I wouldn't wanna `run with them.
I don't wannabe around them.
I don't want nothing to do with them.
I don't wanna get caught up in their.
But these fools would be
cruising with them in a car,
with a shotgun, hanging out the door
and I'd be like, damn.
And I would ask them after,
"How do you kick it with this
dude and feel comfortable?"
I can't feel comfortable
to kick it with somebody.
that's actually someone
because of the fact that
any move you do wrong, you're
gonna be held accountable for
you know what I'm saying?
And you know, going through
the hood as a youngster
I wanted to be the best
I could be in my hood.
I wanted to be that hood star.
I wanted to put in the work.
I didn't wanna get told
nothing by my homeys.
I wanted to just do what I had to do.
And it went like that for a while.
It did, it did.
But then you got these
homeys, they get out of jail.
And I don't know who these fuckers are.
They come to the hood,
he jumps up his car.
I pulled out a gun and point it at him.
Now my homey's got me
and they're scolding me
because I pulled a gun on my older homey.
But yet he jumped out of the car,
like he was gonna do something.
I don't know this guy.
He just finished doing 20 years.
I was just a kid when he went to jail.
Now he jumps out of his car
and I pull a gun at him.
Now I'm in trouble.
You know what I'm saying?
It was just like, with my
cousins when they would come,
a couple of times we drew down on 'em,
not knowing that there were our cousins.
My aunt gets off the car.
Now we're in trouble.
My grandmother's gonna fuck us up
because we pulled a gun out on our aunt.
You know what I mean?
But that's what the
difficult part of growing up
when you have cousins from other hoods
and you're also their enemy,
you know, it was really hard.
You know what I mean?
Because I'm telling you, he
used to come to our house
and my homeys are deep.
And I had homeys that would
disrespect my cousins.
And I'd be like, hey, what
the fuck you doing dawg?
Fuck that motherfucker.
I said, yeah, okay, fuck that motherfucker
but catch him at a different time.
Right now he's visiting my grandmother.
You know, it's not a
time to bang right now.
But a lotta homeys are hard headed
and they're like, fuck that motherfucker.
Cause we're main enemies.
We're killing each other.
But yet these are my cousins.
That's my blood you know, it just happened
that they grew up on
that side of the town.
We grew up on this side of town.
There are a lotta times I would tell them
you should have been from over here.
But then again, they're my cousins.
And in my head I say,
well that's the reason
that hood's so strong because they got
individuals like him that keep it going
cause I'm the type of individual
that keeps my hood going.
And everybody has those individuals.
But the way we had them was
three of my cousins from over here,
five of them from over
here, seven from over here.
And it was like, fuck what do we do
when we meet up and their
homeys are tripping,
our homeys are tripping.
What's gonna happen?
And you know that all through the years
all kinds of shit took place
but we never ever disrespected each other.
Except the one time that I
had to shoot at my cousin
at my house because he disrespected
my grandmother and his mom.
But you know, I wanted to
share that with you today
because of the fact that
there's a lot of people out here
that are from the hood,
and it's only them.
Imagine being from your hood,
and there's like 15 in your
family members from the hood.
And then there's family
members from other hoods.
And when you're doing
things you gotta remember,
everybody's giving their opinion.
Everybody's saying what
they think should happen.
You know what I mean?
I used to have ladies come and
ask me not to hurt their son.
I'm like lady, I don't even know you
but this lady knows exactly about me.
I find out that she's my aunt's friend.
Used to work with her over here
but her son's coming through
all I would tell her was
tell your son not to write
on the walls, not to cruise
through my hood and not
to be with my homegirls.
Other than that, he's cool.
What happens the next week?
I catch the motherfucker
writing on the walls.
Why did his mom even come for?
That's what I used to ask myself.
Why are these dudes moms coming
asking me not to do anything to him.
And then the next week
they're fucking doing exactly
what I told her mom to tell him not,
what I don't want him doing.
You know what I mean?
And I remember the moms used to come
and I used to tell them
even I gonna tell you right now
what I don't want him doing,
your boy's still gonna do that.
And they would say, well, but
we don't want you to kill him.
And I'm like, Whoa, whoa,
wait, wait, wait, wait
you don't want me?
I don't even know what
you're talking about.
And coming from older ladies.
Older ladies that have jobs,
that are citizens, you know.
That don't in the gang bang shit.
And they come and ask me that.
A lotta times I would look at them like,
" Whoa how could you even
say something like that?"
"How can you even put
anything out there like that?"
"Where did you hear this about me?"
You know, "You had to
hear it from somebody
because you're telling
me not to kill you boy.
Like, what are you talking about?"
I don't even do that,
but yet you're asking me
and she's asking me with a sincere heart.
Some of 'em would cry.
You know, some of 'em were telling me,
I tell him time and time
again, not to do this,
but he don't listen.
And then I would tell
'em, I heard their dead.
It's your fault cause you let him
get into that fucking hood.
You're my uncle, and you're from the hood.
But you let my cousin
come from another hood.
How does that work?
That'd be like, my father
letting me and my little brother
and come from our enemy
hood and gang bang.
against my own family.
That's what I didn't understand.
Cause a lotta my uncles had sons
from my enemy hood and I'd be like
how the fuck does that work?
You know, we're gonna go break the windows
on his house and find out
that it's my aunt's house.
After we break the windows
and shit, we get home,
my grandmother's whipping
the shit out of us.
Cause we went and broke our aunts
fucking windows at her house.
Not knowing that was our aunt's house.
Not knowing that was our cousin.
We ain't seen the motherfucker in years.
All of a sudden he's all
banged out, throwing up signs.
He's our enemy, we break all his windows
And it's my aunt's house.
Now she's sitting in the living room.
My grandma's fucking us up
talking about you broke all her windows.
Now we gotta pay for the windows.
But, no one told us
that this was our aunt.
Nobody let us know.
All we know that this little
fucker came to the house
threw a brick at us.
We went back to his house
broke all his windows, lo and behold.
It's my aunt's house.
Well, I wanted to share
that with you today, Mark
because you know, each time I come
I like to share something different
this time I just shared having
family members from the hood.
It ain't always what
it's cracked up to be.
You know what I mean?
Because they're pulling from
every direction, you know?
And, you get tired of
getting pulled in both ways.
You get tired of people coming
and telling you not to hurt this person
or to stay away from this house
or stay away from this house.
I felt that if my cousin's
gonna come and gang bang
and he's gonna break my grandma's windows,
Imma go break his grandma's windows.
Even if they're sisters,
even if it's my aunt's house
I'm gonna break her windows.
He came and broke my grandma's windows.
I'm just giving him what he gave off.
She's gonna pay for new windows.
You know?
And I used to do tit for tat.
I never went beyond.
I just, you do this to me.
Imma do it to you.
Let's go back and forth.
You know?
And I loved revenge.
You know, I loved revenge
and I dwelt on that, you know
but that's what I got for
you today Mark, you know?
[Mark] Awesome Johnny.
- Cool
- [Mark] Always great.
- [Johnny] Yeah lovely Mark lovely.